es gibt keine behandlung und keinen
impfstoff und kein medikament gegen den
erreger und nizza gehört mit 40 bis 75
prozent rate zu den tödlichsten viren
der welt 1998 trat das virus zum ersten
mal in malaysia auf inzwischen ist es
bis nach indien gelangt wo es bereits
zehn menschen umgebracht hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation vero ist
alarmiert und hat vor dem erreger
gewarnt ist so eine weltweite epidemie
eine pandemie alles über den erreger und
die gefahr die jetzt von ihm ausgeht bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
das ist mal wieder vielen dank an meine
follower bei den messestandort oder auf
unserem neuen desktop server gehen so
viele themenvorschläge ein absolut irre
tausend dank ja was hat 98 trat das
ehepaar virus zum ersten mal lauf in
malaysia und das hatte dort absolut
extreme folgen damals wurde das virus
über schweine verbreitet und die
arbeiter und arbeiterinnen in
schlachthäusern steckten sich offenbar
an erkrankten schweinen an die behörden
wussten sich nur mit einem zu helfen
eine million schweine
das waren die hälfte aller schweine im
land wurden getötet und unter strengen
auflagen vernichtet so dass sich niemand
anstecken konnte es gibt nämlich absolut
nichts was gegen die solche hilft keine
impfung kein medikament keine behandlung
40 bis 75 prozent der infizierten
sterben einfach den ersten toten gab es
in indien vor zwei wochen er ging von
einem toten flug und aus der in einem
brunnen gefunden wurde über die
ansteckungswege weiß er noch nicht so
viel in indien vermutet man die
infizierung über die ausscheidungen der
flughunde sie fressen früchte an und
hinterlassen code werden diese früchte
jetzt gegessen oder zusetzten
verarbeitet geraten die viren in den
menschlichen körper
deshalb wird jetzt vor dem verzehr von
angefressenen früchten und säften
gewarnt aber es scheint sich jetzt wie
bei ebola auch die ansteckung von mensch
zu mensch zu entwickeln in indien sind
jetzt pflegerinnen und pfleger erkrankt
hier könnte die ansteckung über
tröpfcheninfektion stattgefunden haben
100 menschen sind inzwischen infiziert
der erreger führt sohn symptomen wie bei
einer grippe hohes fieber
muskelschmerzen kopfschmerzen
halsschmerzen und erbrechen ist der
krankheitsverlauf tödlich kommen
lungenentzündung und einer ebene
tödliche hautentzündung dazu die whu die
weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt jetzt
eindringlich vor dem erreger und fordert
die rasche erforschung sie schätzt die
gefahr für den ausbruch einer pandemie
also einer weltweiten epidemie als hoch
ein
wenn er kein video zum nizza virus und
zu weiteren verlauf und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp untereinander messengern
den link gibt es jetzt hier und nur dann
verpasst ihr
ein video denn die abo box auf youtube
die ist ja immer ziemlich lückenhaft und
über die messenger erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert und dann bekommt er
auch den link zum diskurs server wo ich
im moment mich täglich herumtreiber
einfach hier draufklicken und am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um
social and media abonnieren da erfahrt
ihr das neueste aus der welt der social
media aber nicht die glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken ebola ausbruch im kongo
gerät außer kontrolle
bis dann bleibt dran